the left rushing the blame global
warming for that dangerous Heat Wave
gripping the nation and the world right
now but I think the Heat's getting to
their heads climate change obsessed
Liberals are actually acting crazier
than usual with Eco extremists in
Germany literally gluing their hands to
airport runways as a way to sound the
alarm on how the planet's cooked it
wound up blocking plane traffic at two
airports for hours until officials
ripped the protesters off the concrete
komal is also getting herself into
somewhat of a sticky situation while
pumping up the climate hysteria check
out this huge Gaff she made
every day all across our nation we feel
and see the impact of the climate crisis
it is clear that the clock is not only
ticking it is banging
and we must act think about the impact
on something like public health
when we invest in clean energy and
electric vehicles and reduce population
more of our children can breathe clean
air and drink clean water
the White House forced to clean that one
up
posting a corrected quote-unquote
version of the transcript of her speech
the claims hair is meant to say
pollution instead of population
and while Kamala claims it was just a
gaff liberals seem to agree with it 53
percent of parents say that global
warming affects their decision to have
more kids Greg it was pretty hot over
the weekend do you think it's because of
global warming
um no but
I think that what she did was she
unintentionally said that the true
meaning of what the climate active
activism is they see population as
pollution as something that needs to be
be reduced not the carbon footprint but
your actual literal footprint and then
you see these activists gluing
themselves the thing that drives me
crazy about that is okay as activists
that's their role and I understand that
role but you know that they actually go
home and see their families on holidays
or they'll go on a vacation they do
these things we have to get all of their
personal information out there so that
we know when they're traveling that we
get to make it as difficult as possible
for them right you know because it's
like why like the only this is we know
like if they didn't use Planes Trains or
automobiles then I would respect this in
a way but you know they aren't they're
just they're ruining other people's
lives either temporarily and I think
that's the problem with the climate
movement is they've done more to harm
the environment than actual pollution
because they were hijacked by extremists
and you have all this lost opportunities
for actual debate all the people that
are out that have really fresh ideas
whether it's you know Bjorn lomberg or
shellenberger they're outside the debate
because this debate has been hijacked by
two people people seeking status and
people paying for that status so you
have the the the the corporations and
the people that want to be included in
this they're the ones that are driving
this extremism so Janine how would you
handle one of these protesters gluing
their hands to concrete on the tarmac
well one of the things that I think we
need to recognize is these are like a
bunch of spoiled kids they're trying to
be whatever
um leftists they're trying to make their
you know what make their voices heard so
to speak then truth is they're doing
nothing but engaging in criminal
behavior that is Criminal Behavior and
the more people let them get away with
it and just move them out of the way or
like take a little knife to make sure
the glue comes off so they don't hurt
their hands that are glued to the tarmac
or apparently in Hamburg They delayed
canceled and diverted 47 flights I mean
we we just let them get away with it
same thing with the waltoneris's yacht
they were spray painting it red and
black and they're they're talking about
how she's such a horrible person and the
truth is that you've got a Walmart
heiress who provides 2.1 million jobs
2.1 million jobs in this country okay
and yet they want to criticize her they
want to destroy her boat they want to
say that she's a horrible person I don't
see anybody going after John Kerry's
airplanes but that's I'm sure not
intentional I'm sure it's accidental but
the truth is that you ought to leave
them glued to the floor it just like
they did in one place I don't know what
country I think it was Germany it was
the middle of winter they went in they
glued themselves to this business it may
have been a car sales uh company they
glued themselves to the floor you know
business did they turned out the lights
they turned off the heat they locked
them up in the place for the weekend and
they were moaning on Monday morning we
didn't have any food we had to pee on
ourselves we didn't have any heat you
know what that's the only way to treat
them they're criminals shut them down
and end it is it good enough for the
White House the next day to just draw a
line through a word in the transcript
and then forget about the Kamala comment
well you have a media that is very
incurious right do you remember how much
the media covered kofepe oh right and
then they can't cover this I think
amending transcripts as long as they
announce it or there's an aspect or that
it's clear but that she didn't catch
herself yeah right and say wait I mean
obviously I meant pollution she didn't
but if you watch it closely I've watched
it a couple times I do think she was
like wait was that the right word did I
just say that you know sometimes you do
that when you're and you can't misspeak
when you're speaking live on television
or at a speech you can do that but she
didn't have the sense to catch herself
and also
she might mean it and all she didn't
realize what the implication of that
would be I don't think any of this
discussion is serious unless you're
talking about a way to help people in
the southwest have access to more
affordable energy and access to more
affordable energy if you do that means
there's more Innovation that means
there's money for Innovation Innovation
leads to Great technologies that will
help you power more people there and
their homes so that they can have the
air conditioning that they need and the
same here in the Northeast we covered a
lot of stories a tragic one about the
flooding that's happening in Vermont all
the way up and down the Eastern Seaboard
terrible situation in Bucks County PA
yesterday and what the infrastructure
bill should do is to take a look and say
what do we need to do to reinforce and
adapt to make sure that we can deal with
this not just by saying the Energy
company should go bankrupt and go away
and we should get rid of all those jobs
but to say what's the smart way to deal
with this and there's literally nobody
on the left talking that way
speaking of someone on the left except
for Harold Ford Jr who will say I'm he's
for an all of the above strategies good
to be back here it is good Harold
weekend was good it's good to be back
yeah
so you have record temperatures in a lot
of places across the country including
my home state of Tennessee Texas
Mississippi Florida even and European
nations Poland France Italy seeing
record temperatures Japan and China as
well
now something's going on and I think
Dana everybody's on is something here we
everybody is so comfortable being in
their cocoon that they don't want to
come out and say all right you're right
about this but I'm right about this also
or you may not be right about this I may
not be right about this let's figure out
ways in which to figure out how we build
a new Grid in Texas and across the
Southwest how do we provide more you
know how do we provide more Investments
Dana to your point about Innovations to
help create more energy ample and
resupplies here in our country it
reminds me of when some Democrats like
to say the Cassius Bell is working
they're wrong or when some Republicans
say that everybody should have a gun
even if you kill somebody you beat your
wife or you got the gun illegally that's
wrong
Democrats and Republicans are like those
putting themselves cementing themselves
or trying to glue themselves to the
ground in an airport you do nothing for
the cause but basically make Angry those
on both sides I get it if that anger
translates into US wanting to sit down
and figure out how we reach some common
ground here then it's good but I'm not
sure that does it uh I think Kamal
Harris I heard a fellow in the in the
house the Republican In The House of the
day talk about colored people I hope I
liked a few things in the most favorable
I hope you met people of color and maybe
she mistakenly said reduced population
when she met reduced pollution so I'm
gonna give him the benefit of the doubt
on it but Democrats Republicans alike
the problems are too big the problems
are too severe that's come together and
figured how we get an answer you know
the problem though with this like every
I hate it on the on the right and the
left of using the weather to put to say
it's hot
global warming and then somebody will
like some right winger will go oh it's
freezing oh where's that global warming
so it's they're actually cut from the
same reasoning it's the same thing the
problem with using weather like saying
that like this place broke records
how many states how many countries
didn't break records nobody ever
provides you the context of like three
countries had record-breaking uh heat
waves it's like well how many countries
are there like I'm not is this a quiz
yes it is hold on a second
hey Steve no it's probably like how many
countries are there 800 800 no that's
way too many that's too many countries
too many yeah all right
200 I don't know you know what but
they're comparing these guesses of
global temperatures from hundreds and
hundreds of years ago when people are
195 countries in the world
but the point is as it relates to the
average I mean they're saying from years
ago nobody was keeping numbers 200 years
ago I don't know what they're comparing
it to but they were keeping them 100 I
hear you but they're saying
technology today you can look back and
see but the other point is when it was
hotter back then there were no
Greenhouse there were no man-made
man-made greenhouse gas emissions
I think that Harold's biased I think
you're biased because wherever you are
it's always hotter
I went on Brian Kilmeade I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now